You talk a lot about deer leaves, ubiquitous hypochloridria.
Is that worth trying to determine root cause of this instead of taking HCL supplements forever?
Well, so the root cause of hypochloridria is the question.
What is the root cause?
Well, most assuredly, the root cause of hypochloridria is diet.
So remember, your stomach is the first thing that a toxin is going to come in exposure to.
So let's say you're exposed, you eat foods with glyphosate.
That's as you said, as you're probably the most common toxin that people have been exposed to over the last 50 years.
The glyphosate can damage the stomach. So remember, the hydrochloric acid is made in the pridal cells in the stomach.
And they can be damaged. Whatever damage is damaged, it's going to affect their production of hydrochloric acid.
So it did the extent that they're damaged and continually being damaged is going to be the extent of their inability to produce hydrochloric acid.
So do you have to get to the root cause of that? I don't know how you would accept that.
You just have to just know some biological facts, anything that damages that is going to cause a decreased function.
So I would say just toxins, which we could just read off a zillion of them, dies, additives, flavorings from herbicides to pesticides to keep talking just chemicals that are in our food.
Any foods that you're eating with chemicals that you can't pronounce are all the processed foods.
I mean, our generation by our generation is anybody born after World War II.
That's when these processed foods just started popping up and it's, you know, they're just full of chemicals, you know,
laborings, additives, MSG, all this, you know, stuff that they're now hidden in our food as natural flavorings is the new term for, you know, MSG modified foods that damage our got lighting.
So I don't think we have to look very far to find out what that once is doing that.
And can your stomach heal? Can those cells heal so you don't take HCl forever? I would say, yeah, for sure.
So you stop that stuff. You'll, you'll know you could slow down with your HCl and how much HCl you need to take.
As you feel like you could digest well and you're doing well, your digestion is doing well without having to take as much HCl.